brigitte stand gar aus varel und thomas
thelen aus leverkusen
beide kämpfen seit vielen monaten mit
den folgen ihrer cupid 19 erkrankung
hatte ich wirklich eine ganz schlimme
zeit da wurde ja dieses wunschartikel
bei mir festgestellt
im grunde gab es keinen richtigen weg
aus dieser krankheit heraus inzwischen
kann die ärztin wieder arbeiten während
unternehmer thomas tiere noch weit davon
entfernt ist
ich habe akzeptiert dass das ziel nicht
mehr
der thommy von vorher ist sondern dass
ich erreichen möchte so gesund zu werden
wie ich werden kann und ich werde nie
wieder so gesund wie ich war
wenn die schmerzen in seiner brust es
zulassen dass thomas thelen gerne aktiv
packt mit an
doch das ist nur selten der fall nach
seinem schweren cupid 19 verlauf im märz
vergangenen jahres leidet der 41 jährige
unternehmer unter gleich mehreren folge
erkrankungen konzentrationsprobleme ein
ausgeprägtes erschöpfungssyndrom und
immer wieder schmerzen medikamentös bin
ich jetzt gerade auf dem weg dass mich
von den schmerzen her in eine phase dann
kommen und dass ich halbwegs er trage
die spitzen die immer noch kommen jeden
tag mehrfach das ist halt dann schwierig
zu ertragen aber ich bin echt positiv
gestimmt es fühlt sich so gut an dass
man sich so wahrhaben möchte wahrhaben
dass er krank ist und dass gruner sein
leben verändert hat für immer
thomas fielen im november vergangenen
jahres medikamente sind teil des alltags
geworden
die permanente erschöpfung macht ihn zum
zuschauer wenn seine tochter hannah
aktiv ist und eigentlich mit dem papa
spielen möchte seitdem hat der 25
kilogramm zugenommen das kortison
hinterlässt seine spuren
aber thomas zielen kann wieder ein
bisschen mehr am leben teilhaben wenn
ich dann von den schmerzen her in der
lage wären dann einfach abzuschalten mit
der familie zu spielen dann kann man
sich da auch sein voll drauf einlassen
dann ist das halt ein unterschied wie
vor wo man mit einem gefühl permanent
mit einem sinn immer nur bei den
schmerzen ist sein umfeld die familie
tut thomas thiele gut das zu hause sein
vielleicht der wichtigste schritt zur
genesung aber die familie muss viel
geduld mitbringen und verständnis für
den ehemann und vater haben danach mit
ihm stehen kann arbeiten kann thomas
thiel nicht die meiste zeit verbringt er
in krankenhäusern oder reha zentren
hätten erkrankt
das ist so scheiße
wenn er mal zu hause ist und genügend
energie hat ist die selbsthilfegruppe
für langzeit corona geschädigte ein
wichtiger bestandteil seines lebens
hier tauschen sich betroffene aus und
sie kämpfen um die offizielle
anerkennung ihrer krankheit
jeder der der aktuell beim arzt und
nimmt eine behandlung an ist
versuchskaninchen und jeder hofft darauf
dass das eine therapieform hilft und
bisher gibt es da noch nicht so viel
deshalb ist es glaube ich echt wichtig
dass das die ärzte zum einen wieder was
sie in letzter zeit machen wieder viel
auf uns hören und auch merken wie
wichtig das ist diesen dialogen im
patienten zu haben und in der
klassischen schulmedizin also hier
mensch war es ein fuß gebrochen sechs
wochen gips und und es geht weiter und
das ist bei longo beteiligt weil jeder
seine symptome irgendwo ähnlich hat aber
jeder anders auch brigitte stammte kennt
die verzweifelte suche nach linderung
ihrer lankowitz symptome seitdem es ihr
besser geht arbeitet die radiologin aus
dem niedersächsischen varel wieder in
ihrer praxis monate lang war sie nach
ihrer infektion mit cupid 19 ausgefallen
ihre gelenkschmerzen sind geblieben aber
viele andere symptome sind weg ich bin
wieder da das war das größte wunder was
einem passieren konnte als longo wird
patient kann man wirklich sagen ich bin
so dankbar
noch anfang des jahres litt sie unter
starker erschöpfung schmerzen und
vergesslichkeit an die arbeit mit
radiologischen befunden war gar nicht zu
denken
ja ich war unglaublich angestrengt vom
tag
so kann man das sagen also ich habe mühe
gehabt spazieren zu gehen
alleine das hat mich ja schon richtig
runter gebracht so dass ich dann ja
mindestens eine halbe stunde auf der
couch verbringen musste nach einem
zehnminütigen spaziergang mit dem hund
praxis mitarbeiterin andrea nievenheim
blieb mit brigitte stand ja auch in
dieser zeit in kontakt und erkannte ihre
chefin kaum wieder schon ein unterschied
zu dem was ich seit 18 jahren also eine
powerfrau die nix aus der bahn wirft und
das war schon nicht so schön sie so zu
sehen
jetzt ist sie wieder für ihre patienten
da kommt nicht die füße und werte deren
befunde aus dem mrt aus allerdings nur
stundenweise vollzeit kann sie noch
nicht arbeiten will sich langsam
rantasten um sich nicht zu überfordern
ich merke sofort wann ich an meine
grenzen komme ja die sind nicht
qualitativ sondern einfach von der von
der zeitlichen anforderungen her oder
auch von der menge was ich was ich
arbeite das sagt mir mein körper gleich
normal befunde aus dem mrt analysieren
ihre alltägliche arbeit vor wochen wäre
das für sie noch unmöglich gewesen der
rehaklinik heiligendamm im november 2020
therapie bei dr js frommhold brigitte
standke kann als folge ihrer cupid
erkrankung plötzlich keine einfachen
bilder mehr unterscheiden die
konzentration reicht nicht und die
visuellen reize überfordern sie
um wirklich jeder einzelne ziffer
mit der anderen vergleichen für die 58
jährige ein schock
zum einen kann ich es kaum fassen dass
ich doch sehr ausgeprägtes
fotografisches gedächtnis also zum ganz
großen teil verloren habe ich kann keine
bilder übertragen nicht mehr so
vergleichen
eigentlich anderen patienten ist es
vielleicht nicht ganz so ausgeprägt aber
fast alle haben ja
konzentrationsschwierigkeiten das muss
man schon sagen ich denke auch da wenn
man jetzt wirklich gezielt danach fragen
würde was wir jetzt tun kommen noch viel
viel mehr patienten zum vorschein die
solche einschränkungen haben und das
ganze versuchen sie jetzt auch mal
rückwärts regierte stand gekämpft in der
reha gegen die folgen der krankheit an
versucht mit ausdauer und
koordinationstraining wieder zu der
sportlich agieren frau zu werden die sie
bis dahin war
und kommt doch immer wieder schnell an
ihre grenzen
gerade so was wie koordination ist für
mich überhaupt kein thema gewesen und
jetzt geht das alles nicht und das macht
einen schon ganz schön fertig ich habe
einfach angst dass das nicht wieder
kommt und dass ich in mein altes leben
nicht mehr so zurückkommen
ein hotelzimmer in wiesbaden
hier in hessen probiert thomas vielen
eine neue therapieform aus wieder ist er
dafür wochenlang weg von zu hause mit
nur wenigen ausnahmen
also ich darf oder ich kann an den
wochenenden nach hause und sind das
jetzt war fast fünf sechs wochen mal
wieder von einer überdruck therapie
erhofft sich der 41-jährige eine
verbesserung seiner kognitiven probleme
ein unternehmer der sprach findungs
störungen und schwierigkeiten mit dem
kurzzeitgedächtnis hat kann nicht
arbeiten und verdient kein geld das wird
umso mehr zum problem wenn die
krankenkasse nicht für alle kosten
aufkommen wer aktuell zahl ich es selbst
also jetzt hier die druckkammer therapie
diverse andere ambulante reha maßnahmen
muss ich selber zahlen bezüglich der
druckkammer therapie sieht es gar nicht
schlecht aus dass die krankenkasse das
dann übernimmt
so lassen sich auch vorstellen das ist
ja auch ein neuer weg und ein neuer weg
der bisher für einen krankheitsbild noch
nicht gegangen wurde und versucht wurde
der ist natürlich auch schwer einfach
von der krankenkasse zu sagen auch das
übernehmen wir jetzt vor der therapie
fiebermessen die druckkammer in
wiesbaden in einem stahlzylinder wird
ein überdruck von 1,4 bar erzeugt und
die patienten atmen zweieinhalb stunden
lang reinen sauerstoff
der ablauf kommt der zustand der
patienten wird an monitoren überwacht
eine anerkannte therapieform für longo
wird ist das allerdings auch hier
sammelt man erst erfahrungen mit der
neuen krankheit
wir wissen dass der sauerstoff bei
vielen indikationen hilft hier im
bereich der longo wird geschichte der
fertig geschichte sind wir auf der suche
und haben eine studie initiiert die
national läuft international laufen aber
auch zum thema schon untersuchung fast
20 sitzungen hat thomas tieren schon
hinter sich
tatsächlich zeigen sich jetzt so kurz
nach der therapie kleine erfolge mit für
ihn großer wirkung
aktuell hat es mit mir bewirkt dass ich
sehr schnell beispielsweise sehen jetzt
ihrem buch ich kann wieder lesen das war
zum beispiel ein sehr schneller effekt
auch ein effekt war dass ich während der
sitzung und angel stunden nach der
sitzung diesen sogenannten brain force
den hirn nebel war weg also ich hatte
war wieder deutlich konzentrationsfehler
und das war halt so ein faktor der einem
so viel hoffnung gibt
niemand weiß ob sie überhaupt hilft oder
wie nachhaltig erfolgreich diese
therapieform ist wenn sich der erfolg
nicht einstellt thomas vielen wäre nicht
überrascht rückschläge gab es viele
er hat sich daran gewöhnt und sie als
teil seines lebens akzeptiert
ich habe das gefühl dass es mir etwas
besser geht seitdem ich für mich
akzeptiert habe das nicht mehr gesund
werde oder beziehungsweise werden nie
wieder so gesund wie ich vor der
erkrankung war
und wenn das ziel nicht mehr da ist
sondern da und ich stehe noch da
dann ist der weg nur halb so lang und
das ist dann wieder etwas motivation und
das hilft mir auch diesen weg zu gehen
auch wenn es manche extrem schwerfällt
auf die idee mit der druckkammer kammer
durch brigitte stand wird sie kennen
sich durch eine selbsthilfegruppe
auch sie war in wiesbaden vier wochen
täglich zweieinhalb stunden für sie ein
letzter strohhalm in verzweifelter lage
ich bin voller hoffnung dahin gefahren
hatte aber auch schon so ein bisschen
angst gehabt hätte was ist wenn das
jetzt nicht funktioniert ist wieder da
ohne hoffnung irgendwo auf weiter flur
keiner interessiert sich keiner hat eine
idee wie es weitergehen soll
doch sie hat glück nach der fünften
sitzung spürt sie eine deutliche
veränderung und wer von dem moment da
habe ich ja richtig gemerkt so ich bin
aufgeblüht das ist alles wieder frei es
gibt so leicht es war nicht mehr
anstrengend also das war total toll
der kopf war ohne nebel der vorhang ist
aufgegangen
chefärztin jördis frommhold von der
kurklinik heiligendamm behandelt seit
beginn der pandemie viele lankowitz
patienten auch bei guitar standke und
thomas tieren waren bei ihr
experten schätzen dass es zu 14 prozent
der erwachsenen cupid 19 erkrankten mit
spätfolgen kämpfen und wenn jetzt hier
die zahlen wirklich in die höhe
schnellen sehe ich für uns ein sehr sehr
groß oder schnellwachsenden reha bedarf
da auch und patienten geht dann
weiterhin möglicherweise longo wird
symptome entwickeln wie fertig
symptomatik leistungsminderung aber eben
auch sehr ausgeprägte neurologisch
kognitive einschränkungen ihre ehemalige
patientin brigitte stand gesteht noch
immer mit ihr in kontakt sie hat ihr von
der erfolgreichen therapie in der
druckkammer berichtet aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht ist es jetzt
der beginn mit studien
wir haben ein zwei fallbeispiele wo es
gut funktioniert hat sehr gut
funktioniert hat aber es wäre verfrüht
zu sagen dass das jetzt die ultimative
therapie ist es ist eine möglichkeit die
man erwägen kann und weitere
studienergebnisse müssen eben folgen
brigitte stand gehofft dass studien bald
die wirkung der druckkammer bei posco
witt belegen
denn sie ist überzeugt ohne diese
therapie würde sie heute noch gegen die
schweren folgen ihrer erkrankung
ankämpfen
die alte ich musste dann aber wieder ein
bisschen brennt
weil sie da wieder fünf sachen
gleichzeitig anfängt zu erledigen und
aber ansonsten das ist jetzt schon nett
dass sie wieder so auf den wald stand
der dinge zurückkehrt so langsam dann
aber das ist eben hat sehr lange zeit
gebraucht also fast acht monate es waren
schlimme monate der ungewissheit und der
verzweiflung eine große belastung für
sie und ihre familie
ich bin einfach überglücklich dass ich
diesen weg gefunden habe und ich wünsche
mir das ist auch für mich weiter so geht
und weiter aufwärts geht dass ich
irgendwann wieder vollkommen im leben
ankommen und das wünsche ich auch allen
die noch hoffnungslos zu hause sitzen
dass auch ihnen dieser weg auf getan
wird
seit über einem jahr kämpft thomas
thiele jetzt schon mit longo wird und
niemand weiß wie sich seine krankheit
entwickeln wird er selbst weiß aber
eines nichts und niemand gibt ihm so
viel kraft wie seine familie vergisst
bei der ganzen krankheits thematik danke
zu sagen man war vielleicht selber
vorher der anker der familie und jetzt
ist es meine frau dann sind es meine
schwiegereltern meine tochter nimmt eine
rolle ein die eigentlich von achtjährige
nicht richtig ist familie ist unfassbar
wichtig
[Musik]